some of the latest evacuees from kharkiv
and among them some of the most
vulnerable of the city
still shaken by their ordeal people like
olef who had gone to the city one day
before the war broke out and was stuck
there for a week
we stayed in the shelter of the clinic
people helped and delivered food
yesterday we tried to leave by train and
in my condition it was difficult to move
look what you have done your animals are
you happy now
those were anastasia's last words as she
was leaving kharkiv she is seven months
pregnant and was stuck in a basement in
the southeast part of the city her
neighborhood came under shelling in the
very first moments of the russian
assault and was completely surrounded
we were afraid we had to leave because
in two months i had to give birth and it
would have been impossible the maternity
hospital has been hit so you have to
give birth to your child in the bomb
shelter the metro or the basement you
can only reach the doctor by phone for
the rest you are on your own i don't
know where i will give birth
stories of fear and escape are common to
all those who made it to this school in
a village on the outskirts of the nepal
this is just a transit point people can
stay here for three days have a rest
pick up some clean clothes whatever
other necessities they need but then
they have to start moving again going
west joining those hundreds of thousands
already on the road trying to reach the
closest border
the journey ahead is still very long not
easy for women traveling alone with
children
it took nastya nine hours to get here
she fled luhansk region in eastern
ukraine after her village came under
shelling in the early hours of the
morning she wants to return home but her
like elena doesn't know who will be in
control of her hometown after russia
recognized the self-proclaimed republics
of donetsk and luhansk
we have nowhere to return my mom and
sister are still there we couldn't get
them out as soon as we do we will leave
i don't know where to
as hundreds of thousands of ukrainians
flee to neighboring countries more
people are on the move from eastern
ukraine among them many ethnic russians
which moscow claimed it wanted to
protect
al jazeera in eastern ukraine